First question. After a recent cheap swan test, you suggested two tablespoons per day of the
filing died by one. Since I can't afford $55 a week for one supplement, because that supplement is
about $55 and two tablespoons will probably be consumed in about a week. Should I just skip it or do
whatever I can afford? It was a good question for everybody. Like, what if I can't afford to continue
at the dosage that you asked me to continue at? What should I do? Well, there's really two ways
to do it. You could drop down into a smaller dose per day, or you could take the recommended
just a couple days a week. So if you could afford my dollars a month for that supplement,
by taking it maybe two days a week, maybe taking on some day, that's one way to do it. So
you're getting a higher dose that's affected, affecting the tissue over those two days. That's one
way to take it. So it depends on the supplement. Now, Thailand died by what is the supplement to help
dislodge bad estrogens from the estrogen receptor of the cancer cell itself, cancer membrane,
cell membrane. So in this case, I would suggest you take a lower dosage per day. So with this
supplement, you better have a lower dosage per day so you have some residual dosage in your tissues
on a daily basis. But other supplements, it may be better that did create a video on pulsing
supplements, but in this case, I'd say lower dose per day would be better.